all right you ready for your your quiz
question here you jerk all right sure
sure ask ask me about you know a
question about like somebody i worked
with last week or something like that
like your last trivia question well this
will be easy then this is about your
favorite football team the minnesota
vikings your squad okay it's in in lieu
of our mvp talk the minnesota vikings
have had three
nfl mvps
name them mike florio
all three of them all three of them
you're like mr viking guy let's go
all right nfl mvps
uh i thought there were only two
alan page yep
fran tarkinton right
hi i'm
if you don't get this one i i i mean you
might have to walk off the show wait a
minute wait a minute what am i missing
yeah i don't know only the greatest
running back of our generation but other
than that i don't know oh adrian
peterson
yeah i i completely forgot about it 2012
came on late got 2 thousand yards and
almost set the single season rushing
record and took the mvp away from peyton
manning geez you call yourself a vikings
fan okay here we go well i don't see see
i i that that should prove that they
should revoke my card from back in the
70s my pick will be russell wilson yes
that's the guy i'm going with right off
the bat i mean russell wilson
oh second best quarterback in the game
to me right now
i do think that they got some weapons
around him the offensive line certainly
has been fixed we know how special the
football player is i expect the seahawks
to be you know in the top tier
conversation in the nfc usually to get
into the mvp conversation your team's
got to be really damn good too and i
think all those things line up this year
to where you know russell wilson maybe
he can get a vote for mvp this year like
just one freaking vote but uh he he's at
the top of my list for guys that could
be first time mvps
as we continue to hear over and over
again that he's never gotten a vote for
mvp i just wonder does that fuel his
candidacy to win it he ultimately and
and look it comes down to the
quarterback of the teams that earn the
one seat that's right that last year
that's exactly what it was right in the
afc lamar jackson 14-2 the best team in
the nfl the quarterback of the best team
in the nfl unless unless the the rest of
the team is carrying the quarterback
obviously but never a single mvp vote
for russell wilson although clearly he
deserves to be considered the problem is
it's one vote per voter they need to do
first place second place a great place
uh just just
why why not why not i i there's a
stubbornness to the associated press
when it comes to these awards i think
the idea is there are so many people out
there criticizing so many aspects of the
way they do it that their attitude is
screw all of you we're not changing
anything i mean they have no rules they
let guys split votes if they want to the
the panel of voters needs to be enhanced
frankly uh but i'm not gonna name names
uh and and and you know what i it's
funny i say all the time i'll criticize
the hall of fame process i don't want a
hall of fame vote but i do want an ap
vote i think i should have one i think
you should have one and uh maybe one of
these days we will okay my first uh
candidate is kyla murray because of the
trend
the trend is your friend what have we
seen
2018 nfl mvp second year in the nfl
patrick mahomes 2019 nfl mvp second year
in the nfl lamar jackson we've been
saying it all year get ready for kyle
murray to take the nfl by storm he's
going to throw he's going to run he's
going to score we're going to say oh my
god why weren't we paying attention to
this guy last year well
because he wasn't on tv and we didn't
get to see him very much but when we did
see him we said holy crap so i'm i'm
sticking with the second year
quarterback comes out of nowhere and i
know it cuts against the idea that you
got to be the the quarterback of the
number one seed maybe they'll be the
number one seed who knows but i'm going
with kyle murray well if he did
something like
just insane and just had an unbelievable
year
and statistically it looked good and he
was clutch in the fourth quarter
and they just got in the playoffs
maybe he could pull that off i mean
we're starting to get into those type of
quarterbacks where i think we might
start seeing a little breakage from oh
you have to be the one or two seed i
would like to see that we'll see where
it goes but uh i i totally uh understand
that pick yeah just it's gonna be about
the team i'm with you with the player
i think i'm about to go with drew brees
next i mean drew brees never won it and
a little bit like what you just said
with russell wilson like where the fact
that he's never gotten a vote
will that bolster his chances to get it
i think that's going to be a talking
point this year for you know i expect
the saints to be really good i know that
sean payton and drew brees are going to
put up really damn good stats that's
what they do so that's those are two
things you can go check the box check
the box and i do think the fact that
drew brees has never won an mvp
bothers voters out there i mean two
years ago people were trying to make the
case
for him to win the mvp over patrick
mahomes if you remember who was doing
things we've never seen in the history
of the sport but people were so torn
about oh how could drew brees have never
won an mvp to where i feel like that's
still out there and of course i think
their team's going to be good and the
stats will be good too so uh i'll pick
him as my second pick
yeah it becomes the lifetime achievement
award it does again because you have
human beings voting on it if the saints
end up the one seed in the nfc now look
when they were the one seed in 2009
peyton manning was the mvp because he's
peyton manning and drew brees was the
offensive player of the year that's how
they they split the baby sometimes yeah
that if there's two really great
quarterbacks one is the mvp the other is
the offensive player of the year that's
what happened 11 years ago but if
they're the one seed
i i can see
this idea you know he's riding off into
the sunset they had a great season
fourth straight year where they've been
among the best teams in the nfl they
keep coming back from these these
heart-wrenching playoff losses and yeah
even though the deep ball is long gone
although he says he's somehow worked on
it and it's back i wish we had preseason
games that we could have seen that but
but i and even though maybe he's going
to be used less with with taysom hill
around and and getting eight figures on
his contract i think drew brees is a
candidate if the saints end up that'll
be a big thing though you just said mike
there it's going to be the end of the
season you know because two years ago
like when he was in that conversation it
kind of it kind of you know faltered
down the stretch the things that we've
talked about arm didn't look as good
there wasn't as much pop in the ball we
saw that a little last year too
and i think that'll be probably the
deciding factor once again for him is
how he looks those last three four weeks
of the year
next one for me and i've got a lot of
different ways i can go yeah i'm going
to go i'm going to go to america's team
i'm going to go to a guy who's in a
contract here making 31.4 million that's
a hell of a contract year if you're
making 31.4 but the the presence of mike
mccarthy
the influence that he can bring the work
that he did with aaron rodgers
uh dak prescott uh why not one if the
cowboys end up fulfilling the promise
that their roster has and we know that's
been an issue in recent years they don't
live up to the potential if they somehow
do this year with mccarthy as the head
coach dak prescott's going to get the
votes he's getting the exposure i think
exposure is a big part of it
you see them play if he steps up in
those games where they're nationally
televised and they keep winning and
winning and winning and they finish 12
and four 11 and five one seed two seed
three seed range and dak has a big year
statistically i think we're going to see
him get some votes i agree maybe win it
yeah he was gonna i just i didn't think
he'd go there i was i was gonna make him
my next pick i i really believe that
in a lot of ways that i i really wanted
to pick him before drew brees in some
ways i just didn't think he'd go there
but yeah it could set up to where the
the the gal the cowboys at the end of
this year have to pay dak prescott 75
million dollars a year and he throws her
5 000 yards and everything like that all
right i'm i'm stuck here i got a few of
you good i'm gonna be transparent too i
don't care if you hear it you know hey
derek henry desean watson
carson wentz
big ben phillip rivers i'm going to go
with big ben i think that's the guy i'm
going to go with you know i think
there's a great chance he wins comeback
player of the year but you know again
i think there's a lot of pieces here to
be a super bowl team in pittsburgh it's
a super bowl caliber defense the
offensive line is still good it's not
great but it's good you know running
back position we'll see what happens
there but i think between the addition
of eric ebron the emergence of some of
these young receivers they don't need to
do a lot they were eight and eight last
year with no offense none
so if he has a good just a good
statistical year and good touchdown
interception ratio and like we talk
about they end up being one of the top
teams in the afc
i think big ben could be a little bit
part of like what you said that lifetime
achievement award you know comeback
player of the year love affair
pittsburgh steelers organization where
he can get it i'll go with him you know
it's funny every time the offense
performs at a high level it's someone
other than ben getting the correction is
the mvp candidate it was antonio brown
yeah receivers never been mvp they were
talking about antonio brown a few years
ago not ben roethlisberger so i don't
think that like i
there's there's a tenuous relationship
there is between ben and the media very
real today you have to get enough of
those people to vote for him and i'm not
sure they're going to do it unless he
does have this great season and we love
the story of redemption and you know
we've seen the videos that the
documentary and and you know he i think
he's trying as he pulls the train into
the station to be more likable because
there was a long period of his career
early on where he wasn't likable and he
wasn't trying to be likable yeah all
right i have so many different
directions i can go in for the last pick
and i thought about
a defensive player but then i thought
you know there's only been two that have
ever won mvp alan page and lawrence
taylor and every once in a while there's
you know talk of aaron donald j why not
but yeah yeah but i didn't i didn't want
to go there because i'd wanted to be
a defensive player who's never really
been in the conversation and i'm not
sure who that would be yeah i'm going to
go
with your guy
from your san francisco 49ers
i'm going to go
with jimmy g
and i and i'm doing it based upon
the basic reasoning i get you of one
seed
quarterback yeah and last year they were
the one seed and he was the quarterback
but lamar jackson was better
look
assuming that your guy kyle shanahan can
press the buttons and you know this is
the grand experiment the flirtation with
tom brady what does it do to wake up a
higher level of performance from jimmy
garoppolo if it works he could win the
mvp if it doesn't he's going to be
backing someone up next year right so i
i'm not predicting that he will but
i hear that i think he can line up that
way yeah yeah with that defense the run
game
shanahan delivers a few completions
every game on a silver platter forum and
then yeah he makes plays hey as much as
we talk about it and of course it'll be
the great success story right i mean you
know last year was 27 and 10 i believe
touchdowns interceptions but hey anybody
wants to talk about is just the mist
throws and the misplays in the super
bowl right so if he comes out they're
good and he's statistically
better than last year and playing better
actually than last year then i'm with
you i think he will be in that
conversation no doubt about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports